As you learned in the previous lesson,
focus determines where keyboard
events go in the page.
To give you an example, if I go over and
focus this text input field using
my mouse and then begin typing, the
input receives the keyboard events and
displays the characters
as I've typed them.
The currently focused item is
often indicated by a focus ring,
where the actual styling of that
ring depends on the browser and
any additional styling that
the page author may have applied.
As a user,
you can control which element is
currently focused using your keyboard.
Pressing the Tab key will move
focus forward through the document.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Shift+Tab moves focus backwards.
And you can use the arrow keys to
move focus around within a component.
On MacOS X,
this works a little differently.
While Chrome will always let you
navigate with Tab, you'll need
to press Option+Tab in order to change
focus in other browsers like Safari.
If you like, you can change this by
going to your System Preferences,
going to the Keyboard section,
clicking on the Shortcuts tab and
then changing this radio
group to say All controls.
To give you an example of focus in
the real world, here I am on Wikipedia,
and as I press the Tab key, the browser
is going to navigate through all of
the focusable elements on the page.
Eventually I'll reach a stopping
point and hit Shift+Tab and
now I'm moving backwards
through the page.
This ordering is called,
creatively enough, the tab order.
And making sure your application has a
logical tab order is an important step,
which we're going to cover
later on in this course.
Now built-in interactive HTML
elements like input, button, and
select are all implicitly focusable.
Meaning that they're automatically
inserted in the tab order and
that they also have built-in
keyboard event handling.
But not all elements are focusable.
This header, the paragraph below it,
and this image are not focusable, and
they're not implicitly
inserted in the tab order.
And that's by design.
There's generally no need
to focus something if
a user can't interact with it or
provide it some sort of input.